trafic et les moyens d'médier ça fait un
peu plus de 15 jours que que nous
travaillons nous sommes heureux de vous
avoir avec nous ce matin parce que le le
la complexité du sujet nous commençons à
pénétrer justifie que on continue de
s'imerger et je pense que votre rapport
sera sera utile avant
de vous laisser intervenir les uns et
les autres pour cette HE et demi de
qu'on va passer ensemble euh je vais
rappeler
une dimension formelle de cette
commission d'enquête vous savez qu'un
faux témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait possible des peines
prévues au 434-1 434- 14 et 44-1 du code
pénal et donc je vais vous inviter
chacune et chacun d'entre vous à
prêtcèement dire toute la vérité rien
que la vérité à lever la main droite et
à dire je le
jure je J je merci je vais vous proposer
de peut-être de faire une
présentation liminaire de vous présenter
vous-même on vous laisse vous organiser
et puis ensuite on en engagera le débat
pour croiser vos vos interventions
présentez-vous d'abord et puis après je
vous laisse le le soin de
présenter Yann bizou bonjour maîre de
conférence en droit privé sciences
criminelles à l'université Paul Valérie
de Montpellier et je travaille depuis 30
ans sur la question des drogues et
notamment j'étais co coédacteur du
préidalos de droit de la
drogue claudtille champerche je suis
économiste euh spécialiste des mafias et
notamment de l'infiltration mafieuse
dans l'économie légale et je suis en
poste en tant que maître de conférence à
oknam en criminologie pôle sécurité
défense
renseignement monsieur dame bonjour la
lame je suis directeur de la recherche
et la prospective à l'Institut des
hautes études du ministère de
l'Intérieur je suis économiste de
formation et j'ai travaillé sur sur les
drogues depuis près d'une trentaine
d'années et notamment sur la dimension
économique et en particulier ce qu'on
appelle le lien avec l'économie
souterrainee ou l'économie informelle
c'est selon
merci bonjour davidberger je suis
sociologue je suis actuellement en poste
en tant que Chargé de mission recherche
à milddec et j'ai travaillé pendant 15
20 ans sur l'offre élicite de stupéfiant
le
narcotrafic en France comme à l'
interternational avec un peu de
géopolitique un peu de guyan
voilà alors nous avons transpir un un un
questionnaire un peu pour alimenter euh
réflexion et puis vous dire quels
étaient les les points qui nous
intéressaient euh on on vous laisse
procéder peut-être à un propos
liiminaire chacun et puis on vient en
question réponse ça vous
va très bref je je pense qu' un bref
propos peut-être pour cadrer le sujet de
chacun et puis après on rebandira
euh alors vous nous avez posé neuf
questions et je vous avoue que c'est
vaste
euh peut-être peut-être peut-être
commencer dans un propos liminaire par
une question de définition moi j'ai un
problème de définition par rapport à la
notion de
narcotrafic parce qu'en fait vos
questions sont relativement larges et
visent l'ensemble du trafic al le
narcotrafic en principe c'est le TR
trafic international le crime organisé
les cartels les
mafias qui ne représente aujourd'hui
qu'une partie du trafic de stupéfiants
et une partie qui tend à mon sens à
diminuer donc je pense que là il y a
alors moi dans mon propos j'ai j'ai j'ai
fait une approche beaucoup plus large
d'accord donc je me suis intéressé à
l'ensemble de la question du trafic et
je pense que là il y a quelque chose à
préciser parce que sur certaines
questions ben très clairement la
digitalisation elle est relativement
réduite au niveau du narcotrafic elle
est très forte au niveau du trafic en
général donc vous voyez sur certains
aspects il faudra peut-être avoir avoir
une précision sémantique
ensuite par rapport à vos questions je
on va probablement échanger les uns avec
les autres après euh
j'ai été en fait assez surpris par
euh des une perception qui qui peut-être
n'a pas tous les éléments historiques je
je vais vous prendre tout de suite un
exemple pour me me faire comprendre la
question du trafic en zone rurale la
question du trafic en zone rurale où
vous nous interrogez pour savoir s'il y
a une transformation des mutations et
cetera en fait si vous faites une
recherche historique vous allez voir que
il y a toujours eu du trafic en zone
rurale euh je je vous ai fait la
recherche dans la presse dans la
jurisprudence dès les années 60 on a du
trafic en zone rurale qu'est-ce qui a
changé en zone rurale dans les années 60
la zone rurale est utilisée comme lieu
de production on trouve des laboratoires
clandestins on trouve des cultures
clandestines aujourd'hui ce que vous
avez c'est que c'est devenu un marché
donc c'est le secteur de la distribution
la distribution au détail qui s'est
développé dans les campagnes parce que
Ben vous avez 900000 consommateurs ou
800000 consommateurs quotidien de
cannabis ça vous fait un marché
suffisant pour que ce soit intéressant
pour les trafiquants mais quand on
regarde historiquement la question des
drogues dans les villes moyennes dans
les campagnes elle a toujours existé au
moins moi je suis remonté jusqu'aux
années 60 donc au moins depuis les
années 60 simplement sa nature a changé
et donc c'est une question qu'on a à se
poser par rapport à la nature des
pratiques de trafic sur ces territoires
euh même chose sur sur d'autres aspects
j'évoqué moi le tau THC que que que vous
évoquiez pas je vais vous donner une
note de toute façon que que que j'ai
écrite et et
documenté on a comme ça le
rajeunissement des le rajeunissement des
délinquants participant au trafic je je
vous donnerai les déclarations de la
gendarmerie de l'anon en 2003 se
plaignant d'interpeller des gamins de 12
13 ans participant au trafic donc en
fait la question elle existe depuis 20
ans et et la question qu'on doit se
poser c'est comment depuis 20 ans on a
des autorités qui nous disent il y a des
gamins qui participent au trafic et
comment on n pas réussi à éviter ce ce
phénomène mais on n'est pas sur un
phénomène nouveau là encore voilà
ensuite sur sur la question
euh qui je pense nous occupera beaucoup
de des des des réponses des des
solutions à apporter je j'ai j'ai essayé
de comparer avec en gros on a
actuellement pour moi deux schémas
l'hyperrépression ce qu'on va trouver en
Chine aux Philippines euh du Tertre
c'est c'est le symbole euh donc un
renforcement extrême de la répression
euh aux Philippines ça a été un échec la
Chine prétend avoir des résultats
remarquables ils annoncent 30 % de
baisse des saisis des interpellations
l'année dernière mais en fait c'est lié
au confinement et les Américains
viennent de leur reprocher d'être la
plaque tournante du Fantan hil donc je
suis pas sûr non plus que ce système
chinois il soit il soit efficace l'autre
schéma bah c'est la la légalisation
Canada Uruguay maintenant
Pays-Bas donc là il y a il y a une
question à se poser par rapport aux deux
stratégies qui sont qui se développent
dans dans le monde
et si j'ai un dernier point à évoquer
c'est quand vous nous parlez des failles
et des réussites vous nous interrogez
sur les failles et les réussites les
réussites il y en a une au début je me
suis ben non puisqu'on n pas réussi à
bloquer le trafic et puis en
réfléchissant si il y a une réussite
dans la politique française c'est
contrôle des eiacés
euh on on est quand même parti dans les
années 70 avec une crise des E piacés en
France avec l'héroïn les overdoses et ça
on l'a résolu on n'a pas non plus eu la
crise des opioïdes je touche du bois
mais pour l'instant on l'a toujours pas
eu et je pense par exemple que les
mesures prises en 2017 pour interdire la
la vente sans ordonnance des des des
médicaments codéinés ça a été ça a
participé à ce contrôle efficace donc on
sait faire euh et on a des prohibitions
réussies et je vous rappellerai qu'on a
400 400 produits classés comme
stupéfiants en France à peu près et que
sur ces 400 produits il y en a 10 qui
nous posent un problème et donc 390 ne
nous en pose pas donc il y a des
prohibitions qui marchent et on a des
critères qui nous permettent de dire
quand une prohibition peut fonctionner
et quand elle ne fonctionne pas
voilà merci beaucoup madame choperage
oui alors effectivement moi aussi j'ai
été un peu submergée par la masse de
questions alors je les ai un peu
regroupé euh en trois points je sais pas
si je vais évoquer les trois direct ou
si j'attendrai les questions euh le
premier point c'était la menace
croissante multiform le deuxième point
c'était comprendre les acteurs et et
sortir de l'illusion de savoir parce que
moi j'ai quand même l'impression qu'on
est enfermé dans des dans des concepts
et puis en en troisième point quelques
pistes que faire peut-être qu'on les les
abordera après alors sur la menace je
vais pas non plus insister parce que
j'ai écouté certaines des auditions
précédentes et le point a déjà beaucoup
été fait euh donc je pe pas revenir sur
effectivement certaines substances
stupéfiantes qui qui attirent
l'attention ce que je voudrais dire
c'est qu'il faut faire attention aux
chiffres notamment ceux sur les saisies
les saisis qui augmentent ça peut être
plus de produits qui circulent et ça
peut être aussi parce que on contrôle
plus et donc on saisit plus donc il faut
pas inférer trop de choses de ces
chiffres ça donne une image mais une
image très partielle comme toujours avec
le crime ce que je voudrais dire aussi
c'est que on a une évolution sans doute
dans les modes de consommation not
notamment pour la cocaïne au départ
c'était de la consommation
essentiellement récréative maintenant on
est au-delà du récréatif on a aussi de
la consommation bah pour tenir des
rythmes dans certaines professions donc
ça en terme de compréhension du
consommateur et de lutte contre la
demande il faut absolument tenir compte
on a une banalisation du cannabis alors
que la teneur en THC flambe donc ça
aussi c'est problématique euh on a un
risque qui est annoncé pour les enfin
les nouveaux produits de synthèse et là
ça va poser aussi un problème de de
d'identification des circuits parce que
bah ils passeront pas par les mêmes
routes on peut produire à proximité du
consommateur à la différence de de la
coca qui est produite en Amérique latine
ce qu'il faut voir aussi c'est il y a
une diversité de produits ce qui permet
une diversité de gamme de prix donc on
peut toucher des consommateur de façon
extrêmement large et le même prestataire
peut proposer plusieurs substances
stupéfiantes donc l'offre est vraiment
adaptable je pense aussi qu'il y a eu un
effet covid majeur qui met en évidence
la spécificité des stupes c'est-à-dire
l'addiction contrairement à ce qui a été
annoncé en début de confinement il y a
pas eu un arrêt du trafic de stupéfiants
loin de là il y a eu proposition de
produit de remplacement nouveau mode
d'acheminement ce qui montre l'extrême
résilience criminelle et ça c'est c'est
quelque chose qui vaut pour tous les les
marchés illégaux avec de nouveaux modes
d'approvisionnement l'uérisation hein
les livraisons à domicile les colis
postaux euh ce qui sont devenus
tellement massifs que effectivement on
contrôle plus rien euh les réseaux
sociaux qui permettent d'accéder à à des
sites les promotions par SMS c'est quand
même aussi quelque chose qui s'est
largement développé qui est resté en
place après le après le
confinement dans le même temps du côté
de la cocaïne de la matière base de
cocaïne il y a plus de production à
l'heure actuelle et là aussi il y a eu
un effet covid avec des déplacements de
population qui ont rendu certains
terrain agricole accessible aux
narcotrafiquants avec aussi une économie
de subsistance c'est-à-dire des
populations pauvres qui se sont dit que
bah c'était un revenu comme un autre que
de travailler pour pour les narcos du
côté de la demande le covid c'est aussi
un malaise social un malaise
psychologique qui peut faire basculer
certaines personnes dans dans ces
consommations là donc voilà pour pour la
menace le deuxième point sur lequel je
voulais insister c'est comprendre les
acteurs et et sortir de de l'illusion de
savoir je trouve qu'on a un biais
cognitif dans la dans la compréhension
du crime parfois on veut que le crime
organisé ressemble à l'image qu'on en a
NOTAM notamment une image
cinématographique et je vais parler de
de de trois éléments la violence le
monopole le blanchiment alors quelques
mots la violence c'est ce qui a attiré
notre attention sur le narcotrafic mais
c'est pas complètement un épiphénomène
mais ça ne dit pas tout encore une fois
du trafic de stupéfiants il y avait du
trafic de stupéfiants sans violence et
finalement c'est un un point de
faiblesse pour les organisations
criminelles notamment la mocromafia qui
jusque-l opérait assez tranquillement ce
déploiement de violence à attiré
l'attention les représailles forces de
l'ordre et de la justice au Pays-Bas en
Belgique ce qu'il faut voir c'est qu'il
y a une baisse du prix de la vie he chez
les criminels ça coûte moins cher
d'embaucher un tueur à gage donc ça ça
facilite cette ce recours à la violence
il y a une externalisation de certaines
opérations donc il y a une nébuleuse qui
s'est créée autour des organisations
criminelles ça les communications
cryptées l'ont clairement montré on a
utilisation des jeunes c'est pas Nou
nouveau mais ça se renforce parce qu'il
y a un risque pénal qui est moindre pour
les mineurs parce que les petits dealers
les Chouf ils ont une vision du crime
aussi qui est hyper valorisé valorisante
donc il y a un aspect culturel he dans
le crime qui est souvent passé derrière
on pense qu'à la vision économique il y
a des enjeux de mentalité de culture qui
sont fondamentaux et ces petits petite
mains du crime ne sont pas des affiliés
aux organisations criminelles
c'est-à-dire que quand on les arrête ils
ne savent pas forcément grand-chose des
personnes pour qui il travaillent ce qui
veut dire qu'en terme de collaboration
avec la justice ils sont un peu inutiles
hein donc il y a pas d'intérêt
particulier à à les faire collaborer
alors qu'à côté vous avez des
organisations criminelles de taillees
très différentes très varié hein le
crime organisé c'est une diversité
d'acteurs avec des organisations faibles
des organisations fortes beaucoup de ces
organisations criminelles sont
multiactivités donc bah si elles
subissent des revers dans la drogue
elles continuent de d'opérer ailleurs on
a un rôle qui est peu mis en avant c'est
le rôle des brokers des intermédiaires
dans le trafic de gros de la drogue et
ceuxa on ne les touche pas on n'arrive
pas véritablement à à les interpeller
euh on ne voit encore une fois que ce
qui est visible c'est saisi c'estes
petits dealer les points deal mais c'est
le bas du panier et ça ne ça n'atteint
pas le trafic euh en lui-même et ces
intermédiaires de gros euh ils sont peu
nombreux ils sont pas forcément violents
c'est ça aussi qui fait que on ne les
voit pas parce que ils n'ont plus besoin
de violence ils ont la réputation
criminelle et je pense en particulier au
mafieux calabris dont on sous-estime
largement la menace donc beaucoup
d'acteurs avec des hiérarchies
criminelles avec des coopérations des
externalisations et des effets
d'émulation et d'apprentissage ce qui
fait que la méthode mafieuse se diffuse
sans forcément qu'on ait des
organisations mafieuses au sens réel du
terme absolument pas de struct
monopolistique sur ces marchés alors
pour les économistes c'est la Vulgate
marché illégal et forcément un marché en
monopole c'est faux c'est totalement
faux ça l'est toujours moins et c'est
embêtant lorsque on a des opérations qui
annoncent que il y a eu des mentalement
d'un maxi cartel de la drogue à Dubaï
parce qu'il y a pas de Maxi cartel parce
que ça n'a entraîné aucune rupture dans
l'approvisionnement donc c'est grand
terme ça met en valeur la coopération
internationale mais c'est induire en
erreur peu sur le sujet donc il faut
travailler sur ça d'autant plus qu'il y
a des trafics joints je vous disais ils
sont multiactivités mais rien qu'avec le
trafic de drogue il y a aussi le trafic
d'armes il y a aussi le trafic d'êtres
humains avec la question de la
criminalité forcée les gens qui sont
contraints d'opérer pour les acteurs
illégaux la prostitution vous avez des
personnes qui sont des consommateurs qui
doivent se payer le leur drogue qui
basculle dans la prostitution aussi qui
peuvent tomber dans des réseaux et puis
trafic joint il y a il y a toute la
question de la corruption et la capacité
de réinvestir des sommes he très
importantes dans d'autres trafics donc
des diversifications criminelles qui se
font autre idée reçue c'est le
blanchiment que le blanchiment passerait
toujours par des euh montages hyper
complexes qui demandent des coopérations
avec des des professions spécialisées et
cetera ça existe bien sûr que ça existe
mais il faut bien voir qu'il y a
beaucoup d'argent sale qui circulle non
blanchi dans nos économies euh les
statisticiens des comptes nationaux le
savent la somme des emplois n'est jamais
égale à la somme des ressources c'est
aussi dû à cet argent sale les salaire
de la main d'œuvre criminelle les pots
de vin ne sont pas blanchis c'est de
l'argent sale qui
circule tout à fait librement il faut
voir aussi que vous avez une utilisation
de cash qui peut être peu restreinte
notamment dans l'espace européen alors
pour pour exemple en Hollande au
Luxembourg en Irlande en Hongrie en en
Allemagne en Autriche à Chypre en
Estonie en Finlande il y a pas de limite
à l'utilisation du cash alors parfois
faut un petit peu fournir des
justificatifs mais enfin quand même il y
a une liberté de circulation vous avez
pas mal de blanchiments qu'on appelle de
basse intensité c'est-à-dire le petit
restaurant le bar et cetera qui en plus
fournissent une façade légale
c'est-à-dire que la personne peut dire
bah moi je suis titulaire d' d'un
commerce et ça permet donc de de de et
de s'enraciner territorialement et ça
pour les mafias en particulier c'est
très important vous avez aussi je pense
une complicité de certaines professions
qui sont assujetties pourtant à des
obligations de déclaration des des
affaires des des opérations atypique
peut-être qu'on en reparlera mais aux
États-Unis il y a eu l'affaire finsen en
2020 avec ces institutions financières
qui ont déclaré des soupçons mais qui
avaiit auparavant validé l'opération
finan encière douteuse donc un double
jeu en façade on respecte la conformité
en réalité euh on a quand même cédé aux
sirènes des affaires donc là il y a pas
mal d'exemples dans dans ce sens-là le
marché de l'art aussi est problématique
hein avec un taux de croissance qui a
flambé euh c'est une anomalie économique
vous avez aussi des sociétés tout à fait
légales qui vous aident euh à créer euh
des des sociétés offshore hein c'est les
sociétés prestataires de servicees aux
sociétés et fiduci euh donc on peut
créer une société écran en toute
légalité et très facilement un quelques
clics sur Internet et c'est fait pour
pas très cher et puis on a des
coopérations criminelles dans le
blanchiment notamment les Chinois
blanchissent de l'argent pour le compte
d'autres organisations criminelles donc
là aussi on sort de la violence on est
dans la coopération criminelle alors que
faire par rapport à tout cela je vais je
vais peut-êre on peut se proposer oui on
va un c'est peut-être plus utile qu'on
continue le constat et puis on fera une
une série d'interventions sur que faire
merci Madame excusez-moi de vous couper
pas de
souci alors sans doute certains éléments
vont vont se recouper avec ce qu'on dit
mes mes
prédécesseurs d'abord en en prolégomène
peut-être vous dire que il y a d'abord
une dimension épistémologique
c'est-à-dire que en économie quand on
travaille sur sur les drogues c'est
c'est c'est assez compliqué parce que
quand on on est dans ce qu'on appelle
l'économie standard ou l'économie
néoclassique on n pas de données on n'
pas de données pour faire tourner des
modèles on n' pas de données ou alors
c'est c'est c'est des modèles qu' ont
beaucoup enfin des données pardon qui
ont beaucoup de faiblesse donc on touche
très vite aux limites justement de de de
l'économie en tant que moyen pour
produire de la connaissance donc ça nous
emmène immédiatement à faire de la
pluriisciplinarité de
l'interdisciplinarité donc d'aller
chercher du côté de la sociologie du
côté de l'ethnologie du côté de
l'histoire évidemment du côté du droit
également donc toute cette dimension
pour essayer de comprendre une réalité
qui par définition échappe à
l'observation puisque échappe puisque
par nature cette économie elle est
occulte elle cherche justement à à à se
dissimuler donc donc un véritable enjeu
pour pour nous chercheurs de mettre à
jour cette cette réalité donc si si vous
le permettez je vous propose d'abord de
d'aborder ces questions d'un point de
vue phénoménologique et puis ensuite de
voir quels sont les la quelles sont les
réponses des pouvoirs publics de manière
très schématique hein dans un premier
temps sur la phénomén logie si je puis
dire donc l'économie de la drogue c'est
pas nouveau he évidemment il suffit de
regarder dans l'histoire déjà ces
produits qu'on connaît comme l'héroïne
la cocaïne ou ou les drogues de synthèse
sont pour beaucoup issus de l'économie
légale la cocaïne c'était un produit
légal il y a quelques dizaines d'années
et ensuite donc a eu des conventions
internationales qui l'ont prohibé déjà
partir de là c'est c'est un c'est un
fruit de l'Économie de l'Industrie
Pharmaceutique euh donc c'est c'est un
élément à prendre en compte euh ensuite
donc certains acteurs ont bien ont bien
vu l'intérêt une fois une fois décidé la
prohibition pour des raisons évidemment
de santé publique pour beaucoup mais pas
que aussi pour des raisons aussi de de
lobbying de certaines certains éléments
de l'industrie pharmaceutique il y a eu
donc une opportunité pour un certain
nombre d'acteurs je pense à la période
en France de la French Connection la
French Connection c'est c'est simple
c'est tout simplement une façon d'
d'exploiter cette cette manne
considérable donc je rappelle c'est
simplement donc la la morphine base qui
arrivait donc pour pour l'essentiel qui
venait donc d'Asie du Sud-Est qui
arrivait en Turquie et et qui a été
ensuite acheminé pour beaucoup dans le
sud de la France mais pas que et des
laboratoire transformait la morphine
base en héroïne et cette héroïne partait
en Amérique du Nord pour pour pour
beaucoup et euh à contribué a contribué
à à cette émergence de d'une d'une un
véritable
problème de santé publique aux
États-Unis au Canada et dans une moindre
mesure au Mexique donc je reviens pas
sur la période donc Richard Nixon qui
fait la la guerre la drogue et qui met
un peu la France jeux pas dire en
demeure mais en tout cas qui la qui la
pointe du doigt et qui et qui dit
justement il s'agit de prendre le
problème àpr le corp donc pourquoi je
reviens sur cette dimension historique
parce qu'il y a des acteurs qu'on va
retrouver un peu plus tard dans dans
dans l'économie que ce soit de la
cocaïne ou du cannabis de des acteurs du
du grand banditisme ou donc il avait une
espèce de de de ité là entre le grand
banditisme et ces acteurs du trafic on
avait de très bons chimistes qui sont
partis en en Colombie et qu'on
transforma donc qu'on participa à la
transformation de la coca en en cocaïne
donc il il y a une histoire et puis et
puis petit à petit cette économie compte
tenu de la répression elle elle a aussi
elle a besoin de trouver des débouchés
donc en France on a pu voir dans les
années 80 justement l'émergence d'une
véritable épidémie d'héroïne avec avec
tout son lot de de d'overdose et et de
problème de santé publique et les
acteurs à l'époque étai étaient déjà des
acteurs de de la French en tout cas en
terme de d'offre de cette héroïne pour
pourquoi présenter l'héroïne parce qu'il
y a ensuite des liens avec l'économie du
cannabis c'est-à-dire que également ces
acteurs du grand banditisme ont pu de
temps à autre faire des monter au au
braquage comme on dit et puis ensuite
faire un peu de trafic de stupéfiant
dans les dans les années 80 90 on a
réalisé un travail plutôt dans les
années 90 d'ailleurs avec David
vanberger un travail un peu je dirais
fondateur puisqu'on a fait un premier
travail qui s'appelait l'économie
souterraine de la drogue dans les années
au début des années 90 sous l'égide du
Conseil national des Villes à l'époque
et et déjà on arrivait à à à pointer du
doigt tout un ensemble d'éléments qu'on
retrouve aujourd'hui donc il y a des
phénomènes il y a des
permanences la le
rajunissement la question du modèle du
trafiquant
déjà apparaissait modèle de réussite
entre guillemets la la question de
l'argent facile justement qui émergeit
et à l'époque justement je vais souvenir
de de Patrick Devedjan qui
était qui était l'animateur de ce groupe
de travail et on parlait de dériv
mafieus des quartiers alors c'est encore
encore un usage abusif du terme mafieux
comme comme le dirait clotild mais pour
montrer que justement il y avait une
préoccupation une préoccupation parce
que il y avait de la violence il y avait
un impact sur la vie la vie sociale
locale et euh et donc déjà émerger tout
un ensemble de questions qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui hein typiquement sur le sur
les jeunes qui sontgalement dans le
trafic qui sort du système scolaire qui
enfin qui qui sont qui il y avait une
armée de réserve pour pour ces
trafiquants beaucoup perdaient en fait
les quartiers la conclusion je dirais
finale de ce travail c'était de dire les
quartiers perdent plus qu'ils ne gagnent
en réalité euh puisque ce ceux qui
gagnent sont sont plus sont pas dans les
quartiers sont ailleurs et le souci des
des trafiquants juste justement c'est de
sortir des des zones de des zones de
relégation et et et de profiter de leur
des ressources du
trafic rapidement sur la réponse des
pouvoirs publics comment elle a évolué
donc on on voit bien
l'importance de de la montée en
puissance justement des des des acteurs
policiers dans dans le travail d'enquête
je crois que ce qui a été un tournant
fondamental c'est la loi Perben 2 qui a
donner des moyens considérables en terme
de de pouvoir d'enquête notamment avec
la question de l'infiltration la
question des
écoute et puis le le le début de du la
notion de repenti même si elle est pas
entré en vigueur complètement donc la
loi per ben 2 et puis ensuite on a
progressivement ce qui est constitué un
peu le parent pauvre de la réponse de
l'État la coordination et et et et aussi
la question de l' la coopération
internationale on voit bien que les
drogues nous propulsent immédiatement
dans la la sphère internationale et se
pose la question de la la coopération
internationale donc l'intérêt d'avoir
Interpol europool l'organisme des
Nations Unies de lutte contre les
drogues et le crime tous ces organismes
ont joué un rôle important dans
justement dans la mise à jour de ces
phénomènes et dans la répones des
pouvoirs publics à l'échelle locale ça
été plus balbuciant parce que pour avoir
travaillé sur ces phénomènes je dirais
qu' il y avait il y avait une antinomie
entre les les policiers par exemple la
police ce qu'on appelle la police
judiciaire départementale qui
s'intéressait plutôt au au milieu du
spectre au bas du spectre et puis
l'ertis à l'époque le fils central
répression deafrique du trafic illicite
de stupéfiant qui s'intéressait au
duprak et d'un point de vue économique
ce qu'on a constaté c'est que en en
travaillant sur le bas du spectre le
travail de police départementale
contribuait à faire émerger à avoir un
effet sélectif c'est-à-dire que c'était
les trafiquants qui étaient les moins
aguéris les moins professionnels qui se
faisaient interpell et ça avait une
espèce d'influence et ça ça contribuait
à une forme de monopolisation ou
oligopolisation et inversement quand
l'ertis s'attaquait
au têtees de réseau il avait tendance à
faire ce qu'on appelle en économie une
politique antitrust c'estàdire que la
place est laissée libre et ça créer une
espèce de dynamique auprès des des trafi
des petits trafiquants pour prendre la
place de de ce trafi de ce trafiquant
qui était interpellé et puis on
reviendra peut-être sur la dimension de
la violence dans dans un dans un temps
ultérieur merci merci de ce prop
introductif
monsieuron je vous remercie pour cette
invitation je vais d'être bref en propos
liminire euh je pense que déjà ça a été
évoqué l'approche de marché apporte
énormément de choses sur sur le
narcotrafic hein donc l'offre la demande
on oublie parfois de rajouter la
régulation on pourrait parler de réponse
publique ces trois famille d'acteurs
interviennent dans la construction du
phénomène euh vous avez demandé des
questions sur les routes de la drogue
c'est extrêmement difficile pourquoi
parce que il y a il y a un concept
relativement simple qu'on qu'on utilise
beaucoup en géopolitique des droges qui
s'appelle l'effet fait ballon quand la
pression répressive appuie sur un côté
du ballon l'air va de l'autre côté et en
fait c'est une image pour identifier
cette éternel jeu d'adaptation entre les
narcotrafiquants et les forces de
l'ordre
euh aujourd'hui pour moi le marché
euh il y aurait peut-être trois mots
importants le premier mot c'est
euh la globalisation des échanges et on
le voit avec la cocaïne on est surtout
avec la cocaïne on est dans une économie
globalisée le prix de vente de la
cocaïne au gros en Amérique latine et en
France l'écart a réduit il est quasiment
similaire ce qui montre qu'il y a une
offre extrêmement extrêmement présente
prolifique ça a été déjà présenté dans
d'autres auditions et ça c'est important
de le savoir et donc la cocaïne rentre
de partout euh j'ai entendu lors d'une
des auditions une une des des des
adjectifs sur le le phénomène de la
cocaïne en France et en Europe je
souscris à ça nous sommes confrontés à
une un déferlement de la cocaïne depuis
quelques années qui en fait aujourd'hui
on l'a vu notamment au Pays-Bas ça aussi
été évoqué dans ce qui émerge bien dans
les affaires encrochat es cc qui
aujourd'hui peuvent
représenter un vrai danger pour les
états de droit on l'avait vu en Amérique
latine c'était classique on considère un
peu que ça n'arriverait jamais en France
hein c'est un peu l'effet de chernoby
aujourd'hui on peut se poser la question
on voit ce qui s'est passé notamment au
Pays-Bas l'autre point c'est la
professionnalisation qui va avec
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui les
narcotrafiquants sont extrêmement
performants et là-dessus pour aller très
rapidement ça s'articule notamment avec
les nouvelles technologies qui
interviennent sur l'ensemble de la
chaîne de valeur de la production à la
vente au détail on pourra rentrer dans
les détails mais effectivement il y a un
boom technologique qui intervient dans
l'ensemble des ACT activité humaine ou
presque et le trafic de stupéfiants
n'est pas épargné ce sont de nouveaux
challenges qui ont été bien présentés
dans les préc précédentes auditions
euh pour moi en tant que chercheur et
puis aussi pour am mil DESC la cocaïne
est devenue aujourd'hui l'enjeu majeur
tant en terme de santé publique de lutte
contre les trafics c'est vraiment
là-dessus qu'il faut travailler euh
Guillaume ergne le directeur l'OFDT vous
a présenté quelques chiffres en primeur
euh qu'est-ce qu'on remarque c'est qu'en
fait depuis 15 ans le marché de la
cocainne double tous les 5 7 ans il on a
des régions qui sont extrêmement exposé
la Guyane les Antilles je vais m'arrêter
2 minutes sur la Guyane qui a énormément
changé en 15 ans l'économie guyanaise la
vie guyanaise a changé la Guyane
vit en tension avec le trafic de cocaïne
la raison principale est qu'ils sont à
1800 km des zones de production je vais
aller assez rapidement je vais juste
revenir sur la réponse publique qui a
été bien présentée lors des précédentes
auditions euh c'est un problème
difficile hein la lutte contre les
narcotrafic et ce qu'on a pu
voir dans les expériences à l'étranger
avec d'autres polices c'est qu'en fait
la plupart des polices sont confronté au
mêm problème il y a pas vraiment de
spécificité français dans les
problématiques relatives à
l'amélioration les forces et les
faiblesses de de la police antidrogue on
y reviendra la police française est
plutôt une police antidrogue qui fait
qui au haut du panier si on regarde ce
qui se passe à l'international mais euh
il y a il y a il y a des choses qui sont
problématiques on a évoqué des chiffres
les saisies qui sont des indicateurs
phares extrêmement important hein parce
que quand même retirer du produit du
marché alors ça réduit plus la
disponibilité parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de stock mais en revanche et je parle
sous le contrôle de mes amis économistes
ça intervient sur le prix donc en gros
ça augmente quand même le prix de vente
au détail
mais tout ça est à réfléchir et ce qui a
été engagé en France depuis quelques
années va dans le bon
sens enfin et c'est un peu lié il faut
une approche stratégique il faut des
indicateurs robustes il faut des
analyses qui montent en puissance nous
sommes peu d'experts en France à
l'étranger à travailler sur ce sujet les
données sont fragiles sont Labil il y a
des marges de progression moi c'est un
enfin c'est une de mes activités
principales à la mil des cas c'est de
monter un programme de piloter un
programme de recherche appliqué à la
lutte antidrogue de faire émerger en
fait les travaux de recherche de qualité
qui sont utiles à l'action publique et
de de dynamiser ou de faire émerger une
vraie communauté de recherche qui
permettra à la fois d'éclairer les
décideurs publics les élus mais aussi
d'éclairer je dirais les autorités en
charge de la répression et de l'action
contre la lutte antidrogue je vous
remercie merci beaucoup de vous prêter
cet exercice intenable mais on va
essayer de de tirer le meilleur de
l'heure de débat qui nous reste et je
pare la parole tout de suite à notre
rapporteur htien blanc très bien pour
rentrer dans le vif du sujet et parler
de manière très concrète est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous pouvez nous donner
quelques pistes sur les faiblesses du
système français de lutte contre le
narcotrafic est-ce que vous avez
identifié et
hiérarchisé ces faiblesses
oui moi j'en veux moi j'en cible deux
une au niveau de la loi une au niveau
des de de l'action policière au niveau
de la loi petit rappel vous avez voté
sans loi sur les stupes depuis le 31
décembre 1970 22 lois depuis mai 2017
soit une loi tous les 3 mois et demi à
peu près en matière de
stupéfiant c'est énorme c'est
considérable
euh et jamais en fait on ne s'interroge
et j'ai été auditionné par la mission de
l'Assemblée nationale je leur ai signalé
je vous le signale aussi c'est à ma
connaissance la première fois que vous
avez des missions parlementaires sur la
question du trafic et de
l'action publique en matière de trafic
on en a eu beaucoup sur l'usage on a eu
beaucoup de commissions sur l'usage on a
eu des commissions siblé sur la Guyane
notamment il y a il y a quelques années
he mais sur le trafic de façon globale à
ma connaissance c'est la première moi
j'ai j'ai recherché j'en ai pas trouvé
auparavant donc en fait on on on a
multiplié les textes mais on s'est
jamais interrogé sur leur efficacité et
il y a un terme pour ça alors c'est un
barbarisme ça s'appelle le le le
collègue c'est un Allemand qui avait
utilisé le terme qui il appelle ça
l'utopoyest
gunterner en fait c'est une chose toute
bête c'est que la loi sert à se
justifier elle-même donc on n pas besoin
de l'évaluer on part de la loi et on dit
la loi ne fonctionne pas si si elle ne
fonctionne pas c'est qu'il y a pas assez
de loi donc on va rajouter de la loi oui
mais ça fonctionne toujours pas bah
alors c'est qu'il y en a pas ass et et
donc on rediscute pas le le postulat de
départ et ça à mon avis c'est une une
des choses un des points un des points
sur lesquels il faut vous interroger
j'ai pris dans dans la note que je vais
vous envoyer l'exemple du GBL donc le le
vous avez tous entendu parler du GHB
drogue du viol ou ce que vous voulez
aujourd'hui les les gens consomment
plutôt du GBL parce que c'est un
lubrifiant qu'on peut trouver en vente
libre dans sur Internet et quand vous
l'absorbez il se transforme dans votre
estomac en GHB voilà donc c'est facile à
d'accès en 2011 on a interdit la
commercialisation du GBL en France pour
éviter justement ce type de détournement
eu un un travail très intéressant qui a
été fait par les centres d'
dictovigilance en 2015 évaluation du
dispositive aucune modification même
nombre d'accidents même nombre de cisin
des centres antipoison rien n'a changé
alors qu'on avait essayer par une
disposition réglementaire cette fois-ci
de d'intervenir donc je pense que là il
y a il y a une question à se poser sur
les outils et les moyens et ça m'amène à
ma deuxième critique la question des
méthodes je je je serais plus sévère sur
la question la question de l'action
policière moi j'ai vraiment l'impression
qu'on a une police du du du 20e siècle
et encore une police en fait
inspirée de la police américaine des
années 50 pour le trafic du 21e siècle
et donc on
est on vise deux deux bouts du spectre
on vise avec
l'ofast qui est un rebranding de de de
l'ancienne
ocrtis on vise le le le le
narcotrafic les mafias et ça on le sait
très bien faire ça savent très bien
faire on vise de l'autre côté l'usager
mais en fait ce qui s'est développé ces
10 dernières années c'est un trafic
intermédiaire si vous lisez toute la
toute la la littérature scientifique
tous les articles vous disent la même
chose qu'est-ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
c'est des structures informelles
d'opportunités des gens qui ne se
connaissent pas avant et qui vont se
réunir pour faire un coup et là je suis
désolé les méthodes proactives
l'infiltration tout ces dispositifs là
ça sert à rien parce qu'on a pas le
temps d'infiltrer parce que les gars ils
vont faire un coup et puis après ils
vont passer à autre chose et peut-être
qu'ils se retrouveront 2 ans ou 3 ans
après sur une autre affaire et et et ça
ça rend le travail policier beaucoup
plus compliqué parce qu'en fait
finalement une mafia c'est assez simple
il faut arriver à il y a des risques il
faut arriver à l'infiltrer mais une fois
qu'on l'a infiltré on a les tenants les
aboutissant quand vous avez des gens qui
par opportunité vont se rencontrer vont
monter un coup une affaire à un million
ou à 2 millions de dollars et puis après
ça va disparaître et ils reviendront
peut-être jamais sur le sujet là ça
devient très compliqué pour la police et
et et et je pense que
dans cette dimension là elle est pas du
tout appréhendée ensuite ce qu'on voit
c'est la question en effet de la
digitalisation mais là j'insiste d'où
mon mon propos
préliminaire le narcotrafic il est il
est touché par par la digitalisation à
deux niveaux à la logistique le
blanchiment pour le reste le narcotrafic
qui s'occupe pas de la vente au détail
par exemple donc toute la digitalisation
de la vente au détail je je vous ai fait
je vous le ferai circuler mais si vous
arrivez à voir j'ai un compte Twitter
d'accord j'ai un compte Twitter et je
tweet sur les drogues donc j'ai des
hashtags cannabis cocaïne qu'est-ce que
je reçois je reçois des des demandes
d'adhésion hein voilà des des followers
euh qui me donne un message tél
bonne B pas cherin et le compte va
rester ouvert 24h 48 he sur Twitter va
renvoyer vers un numéro télgram et puis
bah si ça m'intéresse voilà ça y est
j'ai le contact avec le et et au bout de
48 he le lien va disparaître on m
proposera un autre donc mais ça c'est
pas le narcotrafic ça c'est de nouvelles
formes de trafic qui se sont digitalisé
il y a un article très intéressant qui a
été fait par un
auteur allemand qui montre en fait que
les la la structure n'est pas la même le
narcotrafic il a une base géographique
familiale quasi tribale ce sont des gens
qui se connaissent entre eux pas ce
trafic digitalisé ce trafic digitalisé
il est fait sur des compétences des des
alliances de compétences pour arriver à
à faire d'argent
voilà Monsieur la
lame peut-être je vais être assez rapide
euh il me semble que un un des enjeux
euh
d'importance c'est la question d'
l'évaluation évidemment des politiques
publiques euh je pense qu'on on souffre
en France de de ce manque d'évaluation
que ce soit sur plan de la la
consommation mais en particulier sur les
aspects de trafic et notamment sur
l'impact de de la répression sur
l'évolution des marchés euh on sait qu'
a une capacité forte des organisations à
s'adapter peut-être c'est pas
suffisamment pris en compte alors
évidemment il y a des il y a des il y a
des pistes hein qui sont qui sont
ouvertes notamment sur des questions
stratégiques à l'ofaste ça a été ça a
été musclé hein du côté de l'opaste
justement pour prendre en compte cette
dimension du renseignement parce que les
Anglo-Saxons appelle les l'intelligence
LEED policing donc de prise en compte du
renseignement qui a été fondamental et
et de voir par exemple de de d'anticiper
des des phénomènes ce qui se passe par
exemple aujourd'hui en Europe sur sur la
place de l'herbe de cannabis qui vient
supplanter peu à peu notamment en France
qui était un des gros qui un gros
consommateur de résine de cannabis il
faut pouvoir justement imaginez ce que
ça va produire du côté marocain et du
côté européen euh quid euh alors le
Maroc commence à s'intéresser au
cannabis médical mais tous ces éléments
à mon avis ça devrait phosphorer
davantage euh ensuite j'aimerais
insister également sur deux aspects le
le le premier c'est les indicateurs
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui on reste
sur des indicateurs quantitatifs hein
les saisies les armes le numéraire on on
travaille pas suffisamment par exemple
et les policiers peut-être en souffrant
un peu c'est-à-dire que il faut trouver
des indicateurs par exemple de
démantelllement de réseau euh c'est
c'est c'est pas productif d'un point de
vue quantitatif mais en tout cas il y a
un gros travail qui a été fourni en
amont par les services de police et qui
qui est très peu valorisé or il y a du
renseignement qui est accumulé il y a de
l'information énormément d'information
et ça il faut trouver le moyen de le le
valoriser enfin dernier dernier point
euh ça a été dit d'ailleurs dans les
intervention précédentes la saisie
confiscation là il y a des marges
d'amélioration notamment du côté de la
confiscation euh il y a eu des progrès
considérables mais il y a encore des
marges de manœuvre très importantes et
puis j'en terminerai par là la question
du blanchiment là aussi nous avons à
l'échane internationale le Gaffi qui
fait qui travaille sur des études de cas
mais les trafiquants font preuve d'une
grande imagination je citerai juste un
un un un cas sur lequel nous avons
travaillé d'ailleurs avec David sur la
question des collectes ce qu'on appelait
les collecteur qui utilise un système
ancestral qui s'appelle lawala euh donc
ce système de de blanchiment qui qui qui
qui n'a pas besoin qui qui qui est
traditionnel qui n'a pas besoin même de
circulation d'argent et donc c'est un
système de
compensation oui exactement voilà merci
Madame champerche c'était alors bah
quelques remarques aussi sur sur ces
faiblesse
de à la France en particulier une qui
est plus générale contexte général
d'abord ben je reviens sur cette
question de comprendre le crime moi j'ai
l'impression que quand même on n'est pas
si avancé que ça comprendre le crime
encore une fois tel qu'il est et non pas
tel qu'on imagine ou qu'on voudrait
qu'il soit donc comprendre le crime dans
sa diversité dans sa globalité euh moi
j'ai un problème quand j'entends j'ai
écouté certaines auditions je vois qu'il
y a le l'exemplaire du point sur le
bureau quand j'entends dire que les
organisations criminelles sont des
opérateurs de d'ultra rationalité
économique que leur seule motivation
c'est le profit oui ils aiment
s'enrichir mais il y a pas que ça on est
bien plus loin et quand on commence à
parler de l'État de droit ce sont aussi
des structures alors pas toutes parce
qu'ell n'ont pas toutes encore une fois
la même hiérarchie la même puissance
mais il y en a qui visent le pouvoir
plus que l'économie qui peuvent même
être irrationnel économiquement la mafia
calabraise elle raquette ça lui coûte
plus cher que ça ne lui rapporte très
probablement la mafia calabraise comme
El chapo aussi on l'a vu pendant le
covid ù la la mafia sicilienne qui est
encore vivante malgré ce qu'on en dit et
qui est très puissante qui se réorganise
et qui a conquis d'autres marchés ils
ont opéré des distribution alimentaire
pendant le covid ils ont aidé la
population il y a un consensus social et
ça ça rebondit sur la notion de culture
criminelle qui se diffuse il y a des
légitimités qui se créent des
allégeances criminelles et ça ça
favorise l'illégalité diffuse et c'est
extrêmement problématique donc il
faudrait vraiment comprendre ces
différences entre les organisations
nommer les choses nommer les choses
clairement alors moi quand on parle
d'infiltrer la mafia non une mafia au
sens strict du terme ça ne s'infiltre
pas parce que il y a des modes de
recrutement qui sont hyper spécifiques
la mocro mafia n'est pas une mafia
heureusement les mafias c'est vraiment
des des organisation totale au niveau
criminel donc il faut bien nommer les
choses y compris si on adopte le 416 bis
italien ce qui serait pour moi très
important ça veut pas dire que ça va
remplacer l'association de maléfaiteurs
et qu'on va l'utiliser de façon
indiscriminée au contraire il faut bien
comprendre ça définissez ce ce point
alors les mafias elles sont définies par
un seul pays au monde juridiquement
c'est l'Italie l'article 46 B du code
pénal euh qui liste les caractéristiques
d'une mafia la caractéristque enfin dans
ces listes vous avez la force du lien
associatif qui produit de
l'assujétissement et de l'omerta voit du
silence en interne et en externe
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a pas de
collaborateur de justice il y a pas de
témoin de justice la population se taie
alors l'assujétissement est en cours de
discussion en Italie parce que on est de
plus en plus dans la complicité hein
complicité active ce sont évidemment des
organisations qui commettent des délits
une grande variété de délits et dans le
code pénal italien c'est pas associé au
trafic de stupéfiant ça c'est très
important les mafias ne vivent pas du
trafic de stupéfiant si elles peuvent
ell l'exploitent mais c'est elles en
sortent elles en rentrent c'est pas un
problème pour pour elles et ce qui est
très important c'est le rapport à la
sphère légale une mafia a des activités
économiques légales elle capte les
marchés publics elle détourne l'argent
publ et les mafias et c'est lié
conditionnent la vie politique
c'est-à-dire qu'elles vont conditionner
le vote il y a des échanges ce que les
Italiens appellent le vote d'échange les
mafieux contrôlent des paquets de voix
parce qu'ils contrôlent des territoires
et là on est dans cette logique de
pouvoir ces paquet de voix sont proposés
aux politiciens qui une fois élu rendent
la faveur c'est les marchés publics
c'est les plans d'urbanisme c'est
l'autorisation de construire des centres
commerciaux on a une un nombre de
centres commerciaux en Sicile qui
dépasse la capacité de consommation de
la population apparemment en Corse on a
aussi des dérives de ce genre-là euh ça
peut être même des choses très basiques
et là encore on retombe dans le
consensus social des places en crèche
des places en maison de retraite donc
tout ça ça fausse les rapports à la
démocratie et au pouvoir légal légitime
alors pour bien comprendre le crime et
aussi je pense qu'il faudrait sortir de
la logique de silo qui est très
française
finalement s'attaquer alors l'ophast est
utile l'opast obtenu des résultat mais
je pense que se concentrer sur le marché
des stupes parfois ça permet pas de voir
tout l'ensemble du système on a des
organisations criminelles qui font
système il faut qu'on peut-être casse un
peu cette logique de silo euh la logique
des points de d'Al aussi est-ce que ça a
encore du sens d'avoir cette
cartographie cette
euh comptabiliser les points de Deal
alors qu'on voit que l'ubérisation et
les colis postaux sont en train de de de
monter en gamme euh pas forcément moi
j'avais un maire d'un d'une petite ville
qui me disait nous régulièrement dans le
village il y a une berline qui arrive
qui apporte la marchandise tout le monde
est au courant et la berline repart
c'est même pas un point de Deal c'est
c'est un approvisionnement vite fait
bien fait ce que je regrette aussi dans
cette compréhension c'est et ça rejoint
la question de on a peu d'information
des informations qui sont très
partielles j'aimerais qu'il y ait plus
de coopération entre les chercheurs et
les services il y a
vraiment peut-être un manque de
confiance je ne sais pas moi en tant que
chercheuse je n'ai pas accè au rapport
du casco donc le le service
d'information et de recherche sur la
criminalité organisée donc je ne sais
pas ce qu'il y a dans ce rapport et je
ne peux pas apporter mes compétences
aussi au sirasco parce que je sais des
choses je sur les mafias italiennes je
pense que j'ai des choses à apporter
aussi donc il faudrait quand même
peut-être faciliter des passerelles
d'autres pays le font ça fonctionne
l'Italie puisque je je la connaist bien
développer aussi la formation initiale
et continue euh en tant qu'économiste je
dirais qu'on peut faire un cursus enfin
on fait un cursus en économie en France
sans jamais entendre parler d'économie
criminelle moi ça ça me ça me sidère euh
et euh formation continue aussi pour
pour les les personnels des services ça
rejoint aussi la problématique de la
criminologie en tant que discipline
autonome en France il n'y a pas de
section de criminologie au Conseil
national des universités c'est un
problème parce que la criminologie c'est
pas seulement de la théorie c'est aussi
une criminologie opérationnelle et quand
on voit les travaux des chercheur
criminologue à l'étranger on se dit
qu'on est peut-être un petit peu en
retard sur sur le sujet rapidement un
autre point on n' pas tiré les leçons de
l'Italie je pense que l'Italie a un
temps d'avance même si le combat contre
la mafia n'est pas fini et c'est pas
seulement l'article 416 bis c'est tout
ce qu'il y a autour de ce 416 bis alors
il y a la question des de la saisie des
avoirs criminels qui effectivement pour
moi est fondamentale parce que elle
frappe beaucoup plus large que le
monitorage des flux financiers on va
capter cet argent salale non blanchie
qui circule dans l'économie via les
saisis alors qu'on ne peut pas le faire
par le monitorage parce que aussi il y a
la question de la motivation des agents
vous avez des profession assujetti à des
obligations mais on voit bien que
parfois entre le gain et et la
conformité elles choisissent le gain
quand on est dans la saisie des avoirs
bah c'est des douigners c'est des forces
de l'ordre c'est la justice c'est des
gens qui sont impliqués qui ont envie
que ça aille jusqu'au bout sauf que ça
demande du temps et en Italie c'est
automatique déclencher des enquêtes
patrimonial c'est ça démarre tout de
suite dès qu'il y a inculpation pour
pour mafia et c'est en lien aussi avec
quelque chose qu'on a pas en droit
français qui est la dangerosité sociale
sur le les collaborateurs de justice je
suis un peu plus
nuancé on pourra peut-être y revenir
mais c'est le collaborateur de justice
qui a vraiment énormément d'informations
c'est très rare et c'est peu
reproductible comme comme situation
c'est un lien interpersonnel la
collaboration avec la justice c'est
Falcon et Bouchette c'est c'est c'est
vraiment de l'ordre de l'extraordinaire
alors il faut pouvoir permettre ça qui a
un cadre mais c'est pas non plus la
potion magique qui va faire parler les
criminels et dans le le dispositif
italien il a quelque chose dont on ne
parle pas en tout cas en France moi j'ai
j'en ai pas trop entendu parler c'est le
concours externe en association mafieuse
le concours externe en association
mafieuse c'est pour frapper plus
durement un nona affilié un non criminel
stricto sensu qui apporte siamment
volontairement son concours à
l'organisation criminelle donc là on
frappe la zone grise et cette zone grise
de personnes légal en apparence mais qui
facilite les opérations criminel cette
zone grise elle est assez importante
alors ça va concerner la corruption mais
ça concerne beaucoup d'autres acteurs
aussi et c'est à mon avis c'est très
important parce que si on casse ça on
casse aussi le la capacité à s'étendre
de façon capillaire des organisations
criminelles et ça rejoint une
problématique plus générale mais je je
vais peut-être pas forcément
métendreur David parle aussi mais euh le
l'illégal a des liens avec le légal et
il faut absolument casser ces liens pour
affaiblir les les organisations
criminelles alors il y a il y a
évidemment la corruption mais on a
beaucoup parlé des des messageries
crypté and crotchat au départ c'est une
société légale de télécommunication qui
propose des services dont on voit bien
qu'ils vont plaire aux criminels
qu'est-ce qu'on fait par rapport à ça
qu'est-ce qu'on fait par rapport à la
législation maltaise sur l'industrie du
jeu on a
un cadre juridique qui en théorie ne
permet pas d'investir du cash de parier
du cash sauf que dans la réalité c'est
massivement du cash donc du blanchiment
qui va passer par ce système là et
l'Autorité de régulation maltaise on
sait qu'elle est inefficace qu'elle ne
fait rien en plus avec des problèmes de
conflit d'intérêt majeur et personne ne
fait rien et on a un discours économique
qui est assez problématique ça rejoint
la question des ports on choisit
l'efficience économique on ne contrôle
que 2 % maximum des marchandises en
entrée dans les port européen au
détriment de la sécurité et ça on risque
de le payer très cher à
l'avenir
berger merci alors moi il m'est un peu
difficile de pas parler des forces quand
on parle des faiblesses mais donc je
vais quand même répondre à à vos demande
mais vous rappelez quand même qu'il y a
aussi quelques forces alors comme
j'avais travaillé ma copie je prends la
question 9 et donc
effectivement déjà moi je pense que
depuis quelques années il a été initié
un vrai changement dans la manière de
voir la lutte antidrogue il y a un
changement qui va dans le sens qui a été
évoqué j'ai entendu les auditions de
Madame charbonnier les auditions de la
junalco les auditions des autres
opérateur et on le voit et puis avec
Naser qui pourra le rappeler on voit une
vraie évolution dans la dans la manière
d'appréhender le problème par rapport il
y a une dizaine d'années une quinzaine
d'années donc moi je je trouve ça plutôt
satisfaisant même si il faut rester
humble et continuer à avancer en
améliorant les leviers alors les
principes levier pour moi euh c'est une
meilleure
coordination entre les services mais
aussi
l'innational et là effectivement il y a
des choses qui sont mis en œuvre il faut
le
soutenir ces problématiques et la
coordination on les voit partout
ailleurs dans les autres polices
antidrogue aux États-Unis dans les pays
européens
sud-américain cette cette concurrence
qui a aussi quand même je dirais une
fonction fautut faut se rappeler que de
mettre en concurrence les services les
forces de sécurité intérieure c'est une
fonction pour nos sociétés donc c'est il
faut trouver le bon équilibre
euh la coopération notamment en Europe
et l'international ça ai été évoqué il y
a eu quand même une nette amélioration
avec les outils européens de coopération
très très nette des grands changements
le mandat d'arrêt européen ce genre
d'outils sont extrêmement puissants et
ont permit d'énormes affaires qui
auparavant étaient extrêmement
difficiles donc il faut s'en satisfaire
mais il faut faut améliorer la
coopération la coopération ça renvoie
aussi à l'action de la France à
l'international l'action de la France à
l'internationale et là nous avons un
point fort puisque nous avons des
réseaux d'attachés de sécurité
intérieure les policiers les gendarmes
dans les ambassades qui sont je crois
les 2è ou les 3è au monde après les
États-Unis alors je sais plus si les
Britanniques sont devant nous ou pas
mais on a quand même une grande force on
a des magistralisons on a des Attachés
douiniers ces gens-là peuvent et amènent
en fait d'énormes résultats pour lutter
en à mon de la filière ce qu'on appelle
la théorie du bouclier c'est lutter à
proximité des zones de production des
zones de transit je vous rappelle hein
ça c'est les chiffres de l'ONU 70 % des
saisies mondiales sont de cocaïne sont
faites en Amérique du Sud hein donc il y
a vraiment une stratégie apporter cette
stratégie et là bon je rappelle mon
positionnement institutionnel mais je
suis en train de vous répondre en tant
que chercheur elle est vraiment soutenu
par le fond concours drogue et
l'impulsion d'une entité
interministérielle qui permet de de
mieux coordonner ces actions là est un
vrai plus qui est salué et qui est
recherché dans les pays qui n'ont pas
ces
outils le troisème point qui a été
évoqué
c'est continuer à améliorer les
connaissances scientifiques et
technologiques mieux centraliser les
données et les
partager les actions de formation
évidemment clatil les a évoqué mais
c'est extrêmement important aussi euh ça
a été évoqué c'est très technique mais
soutenir modifier améliorer sans cesse
les outils d'enquête et le cadre du
renseignement euh évidemment il y a des
questions budgétaires qui vont avec ça
vous pouvez aller voir les budgets de la
DEA par par exemple qui sont quand même
enfin c'est le poids lourd de la lutte
antidrogue dans le monde he ils sont
autour de 3 milliards d'euros de
fonction 3 milliards de dollars de
fonctionnement bon il se donnent les
moyens alors c'est sûr c'est un pays
plus riche mais c'est intéressant de le
rappeler d'évoquer que ça peut être
aussi une forme de priorité nationale he
à l'instar de ce qu'on a fait contre sur
la le terrorisme et la lutte contre la
radicalisation et puis voilà avoir des
des des leviers qui facilitent la
coopération interministérielle je le
reviens comme le fond concours
drog alors peut-être qu'on peut procéder
à une série de questions de nos
collègues ce que je vous propose c'est
qu'on fasse des des questions assez
courtes comme vous êtes nombreux avec
nos interlocuteurs aussi et donc Madame
finera or s'il vous
plaît merci président alors j'ai écouté
attentivement vos interventions mon
messieurs dames et alors vous avez parlé
de la Guyane je suis sénatrice de la
Guyane et vous êtes des chercheurs et je
compte sur vous parce que nous avons mis
un dispositif de 100 % contrôle à
l'aéroport et malgré ça les mules
continuent que faut-il faire c'est
vraiment ce fléo s'amplifie en Guyane et
franchement les élus attendent beaucoup
d'ailleurs sur cette commission
d'enquête sénatoriale pour obtenir vous
parlez de coopération international oui
oui mais ça n'empêche pas que chez nous
c'est c'est c'est les parents n'en
peuvent plus les élus n'en peuvent plus
la police n'en peut plus il faut qu'on
trouve une solution même si l'objectif
de cette commission justement est de
proposer des moyens mais je compte sur
vous parce que franchement là les les je
ne cesse d'être interpellé par les
citoyens en disant parce que ce sont des
enfants des enfants et pas forcément de
classe défavorisé ce sont aussi des
enfants des jeunes maintenant ça va J
aux malades qui partent en évacuation
sanitaire c'est grave même s'il un
malaise social mais il faut qu'on arrive
à à à arrêter ce ce ce flux de de de de
de déplacement de enfin de
transport de de de de cocaïne c'est pas
possible on n peut plus en Guyane alors
messieurs dames je compte sur vous vous
êtes des chercheurs moi je n'ai pas la
solution j'aurais bien aimé même s'il y
a eu des dispositifs qui ont été mis euh
sur les arrêtés fait une expérimentation
préfectorale mais ça marche pas ils
savent qu'il y a le contrôle mais ils
viennent quand même on refoule 50
passagers mais bah il y en a qui sont
passés ça c'est clair donc voilà voilà
le Président je vais pas être plus long
je sais qu'il y a d'autres questions
merci chers collèguees d'autres
questions Mons
califé merci beaucoup pour cette
présentation très très très très large
moi j'ai une question qu'on a qu'on a
évoqué que j'ai pas entendu à moins que
ça soit pas un problème c'est le narco
et le terrorisme international personne
n'en a parlé est-ce que c'est une
réalité est-ce que on évite d'en parler
est-ce que c'est
maîtrisable voilà et et la deuxème
question président comme ça je parle
plus après quelle est la l'indépendance
des des structures qui luttent parce que
bon je viens de M on est traumatisé par
l'assassinat du juge Michel à
l'époque à Marseille est-ce que les les
personnes qui travaillent dans ce
domaine sont protégés sont
indépendantes dans leur décision est-ce
qu'ils arrivent à faire leur travail
sans être
menacés merci y a-t-il d'autres
questions non Karine
Daniel monsieur bonus aprs oui merci euh
tout d'abord merci de de de vos
contributions pourra qu'appuyer le fait
que que les services de l'État doivent
se nourrir des des travaux de la
recherche moi je retiens le fait que
tout un
pan
de alors pas ENF oui du trafic est peu
analysé le le pan un peu intermédiaire
donc ça ça doit nous
interpeller moi j'ai une question
concernant les aspects de
production j'ai l'impression qu'on qu'on
ne met jamais le focus sur la production
sa
localisation son contrôle sa maîtrise
éventuelle destruction parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'on cherche toujours à
intervenir très en aval des filières et
et on occulte un peu ce secteur
àont Michel bus
oui merci merci beaucoup je vos
interventions sonraent très engchissante
merci la première question elle est elle
est de l'ordre du voilà sur le parcours
du du jeune trafiquant est-ce que vous
avez travaillé est-ce que nous on peut
éventuellement aider sur la prévention
parce que je suppose qu'il y a il a il y
a des répercussions sur sur sa vie et
deuxième question c'est pourquoi d'après
vous notre pays nous sommes les plus
gros consommateurs de de de cannabis et
et les conséquences et après les
conséquen vous avez parlé de l'illégal
légal c'est vrai que quand il y a une
descente dans un quartier
aujourd'hui l'illégal impacte vraiment
le légal en matière de en matière de
d'économie donc j'aimerais savoir si
vous avez un retour là-dessus j'ai un
petit exemple dans un quartier de Toulon
ben j'ai interrogé j'ai discutéis avec
le le directeur de l'Intermarché il y
avait une grosse descente dans le
quartier de Toulon ben il était en
baisse de 30 % depuis la baisse depuis
depuis la depuis l'intervention de la
police donc tout ça pour nous c'est pour
nous c'est important puis surtout agir
sur la prévention c'est c'est capital
voil
merci j'y ajoute ma propre question sur
un terme qui a été utilisé sur la
criminalité forcée depuis le début de
nos auditions on nous parle de la
corruption mais aussi de la menace et
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a quelque
chose un peu un nœud à à travailler
entre entre la corruption la pas du gain
et puis des des contraintes des menaces
donc est-ce que vous pouvez dire quelque
chose là-dessus qui
s'inscrit dans l'ordre il
euh alors peut-être je je je rebondirai
d'abord sur sur sur le votre votre
remarque madame euh parce qu'en fait
c'est c'est un petit peu si vous voulez
ce que j'ai essayé de signaler au début
c'estàdire que et j'ai entendu aussi les
les les auditions des des différents
acteurs de de de de la sécurité on vous
demande à chaque fois plus de moyens
mais euh vous évoquiez l'Italie mais
dans votre intervention à la fois vous
nous citez les dispositions du droit
italiens qui sont quand même très très
violentes d'un point de vue juridique et
le résultat c'est que la Drang existe
toujours la camera existe toujours donc
euh à un moment donné il va falloir se
questionner sur l'efficacité de ce
dispositif et moi j'ai un exemple de
prohibition réussie c'est 1916 l'opium à
Tahiti c'est très précis en 1916 la
France décide de prohiber l'opium à Titi
ça va mettre 5 ans 2021 ce sera fini et
on a plus de problème d'opium à Tahiti
et en fait à partir de cet exemple on
voit qu'il y a trois conditions une
prohibition réussie il faut première
condition une adhésion sociale c'estàd
que il faut qu' que la communauté que le
collectif il est envie que ça ça que ça
disparaisse il faut une capacité à
appliquer l'interdit et c'était ça qui
était facile à Tahiti il y avait un
bateau par mois euh c'était simple à
contrôler et puis ensuite ce qu'on voit
aussi il faut un produit de substitution
et ça on le voit par exemple avec ce qui
s'est passé sur le cannabis au Maroc et
en Tunisie au moment de la
décolonisation où on a poussé le tabac
et on a poussé le tabac comme
alternative au au cannabis si vous avez
pas ces trois conditions les
prohibitions ça fonctionne pas alors ce
que vous pouvez faire après c'est
réfléchir par exemple à la question des
alternatives euh et et là je je je je
vais je vais revenir sur sur le cannabis
en fait moi je suis très optimiste sur
le cannabis c'est la chance de la France
si vous regardez les statistiques
européennes on dit toujours on est le
premier consommateur de cannabis mais
sur ce on n'est pas le premier pour euh
pour pour la MDMA pour l'ectasie on
n'est pas le premier pour les new
psychoactif substanive c'est-à-dire que
la France a cette particularité d'avoir
une consommation massive monomaniaque de
cannabis qui est lié notamment à
l'histoire avec le Rif et aujourd'hui
pour répondre madame à votre question la
production elle ne se fait plus dans le
Rif elle se fait en Europe hein de parce
que le marché c'est essentiellement de
l'herbe et elle est produite en Europe
euh et et ça c'est pour moi il y a deux
indicateurs intéressants en France c'est
que si on réfléchit sur la question du
cannabis et qu'on arrive à avancer sur
cette question du cannabis par exemple
avec des produits de substitution CBD ou
je sais pas
quoi si on arrive à travailler sur un
autre élément c'est la prévention chez
les jeunes on a une baisse de la
consommation chez les jeunes
profitons-en c'est quand même
intéressant on a un vieillissement de la
de la de l'âge des consommateurs
travaillons là-dessus vous voyez et et
et et ça ça pour moi c'est des des des
points d'optimisme c'est-à-dire que le
marché est focalisé sur le cannabis et
le boom de la cocaïne voilà donc on a
ces deux substances à travailler mais à
côté de ça d'autres pays ils ont agérer
les new
psychoactif l'akéamine qui a explosé en
Chine plus 118 % en un an sur laettamine
en Chine on est on n pas cette
difficulté là pour l'instant en France
d'accord narco et terrorisme
international je vous avoue que oui je
l'ai pas évoqué et jeai pas é voquer non
plus dans ma note parce qu'en fait euh
enfin au niveau français je je je je
vois je vois pas le lien alors on va
parler du captagon on va parler de ces
choses-là ok ça ça touche pas le
territoire français
euh ce qu'on voit là vous avez peut-être
vu la publication c'était ce matin je
crois la Birmanie est devenu le premier
producteur mondial d'opium d'accord
c'est plus l'Afghanistan parce que les
talibans on ont coupé la la production
d'opium en Afghanistan donc finalement
les liens est-ce qu'ils existent est-ce
que dans certains cas ça neutralise pas
aussi la question des
talibans le parcours du jeune trafiquant
par c'est un peu ce que la réflexion que
je faisais sur la question de la
ruralité et trafic et ruralité par qu'en
fait si vous regardez historiquement il
y a toujours eu une utilisation de la
ruralité par le trafic et on voit cette
histoire de jeunes qui qui participent
au trafic déjà dans les années 70 et la
question que je me pose moi et
malheureusement j'ai pas la réponse
c'est pourquoi on n pas réussi à à
apporter une réponse à ça et et pour moi
ça c'est un enjeu majeur se poser la
question de qu'est-ce qui a échoué dans
les politiques publiques françaises
depuis 40 ans ou 50 ans pour que ayant
des gamins de 12 ou 13 ans qui participe
au trafic on n jamais réussi à trouver
une une solution
voilà m oui alors je vais rebondir sur
cette question des des jeunes
trafiquants pour la reconnecter à une
réflexion plus globale j'ai j'ai fini
tout à l'heure en parlant d'un discours
économique qui est problématique j'ai
parlé des des ports globalement et bon
c'est de la théorie économique mais elle
a un impact sur la façon dont on dont
nos économies fonctionnent et nos
sociétés fonctionnent on a quand même un
mouvement vers la déconnexion entre
l'économie et l'éthique hein l'économie
s'autonomise on a même certains
chercheurs qui se revendiquent d'une
hégémonie économique c'est-à-dire que
tout est évalué à l'ône d'instruments
économiques notamment l'efficience
économique la maximisation du profit et
cetera ce qui fait que on a un
glissement dans la perception du rapport
à la loi de ce qu'on ne doit pas faire
quand bien même il y aurait de l'argent
à la clé et ça c'est c'est cette
intériorisation des norme elle disparaît
alors chez le jeune mais aussi dans les
élites et ça c'est problématique dans le
dans la finance on a un marché de la
transgression qui s'est mis en place
très clairement vous avez des banques
qui régulièrement sont condam anné alors
en plus quand c'est le système
anglo-saxon c'est la négociation au
procès qui permet d'éviter la honte du
procès et qui finit par un accord
financier donc on donne un prix à la
transgression euh des exemples de ça
Leng comme un institut bancaire a payé
des amendes pour 775 millions d'euros
pour des failles dans son système
anti-recyclage et c'est à répétition
c'est-à-dire qu'elles sont pas
condamnées une fois et elles font le
travail non elles continuent parce que
finalement ça leur coûte moins cher de
continuer à à fruder HSBC aussi 1,9
milliards de dollars en 2012 pour
recyclage pour le compte des
narcotrafiquants mexicains et violation
d'embargo un autre exemple de ce marché
de la transgression qui se met en place
en 2014 JP Morgan Chase avait provisionn
sa ligne contentieux à hauteur de 23
milliards de dollars on provisionne sa
ligne contentieux parce qu'on sait qu'on
a fait des choses pas propres et que
certaines vont passer à l'AS mais
d'autres vont être identifié et donc on
est dans cette logique de négociation
autour de la fraude le scandale des
Panama papers en 2016 c'était quand même
plus de 500 banques dont des grosses
banques européennes c'est pas les
petites banques hein qui frent ce sont
les grosses qui utilisent les services
du cabinet mossac fonsseeka dont on sait
que il est quand même verreux donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait par rapport à ça et
il y a des processus d'émulation alors
là aussi on est dans l'économie non
standard non orthodoxe mais vous avez
des auteurs comme weblen qui vous disent
que il y a de la consommation
stentatoire et que on se cale sur ce que
font les class supérieur ce que font les
élites s'il y a de la fraude Cerland qui
a expliqué le concept de criminalité en
colleblanc il disait c'est extrêmement
grave c'est plus grave que les vols les
braquages parce que ça mine la confiance
dans les institutions et là on est
vraiment dans cette logique là où il
faut quand même
rétablir l'idée aussi de cause-
conséquence tout simplement si vous
commettez tel acte il y a une sanction
pénale il y a une sanction sociale
c'est-à-dire que normalement il doit y
avoir une réprobation pour ces actes et
puis bah quand vous êtes trafiquant vous
vous distribuez la mort d'une certaine
façon il faut l'entendre et il y a un
décalage alors il y a aussi cette
logique du court terme par rapport au
long terme c'est-à-dire qu'on est dans
l'immédiateté du profit les conséquences
c'est pas grave c'est pour les autres
euh décalage aussi il y avait une
affaire je crois que c'était au port du
Havre avec une une secrétaire qui avait
perçu 10000 € pour insérer une clé USB
dans son ordinateur ce qui avait permis
de pirater le système informatique et
donc de de contrôler l'arrivée des
containerss pour elle c'était totalement
euh déconnecté alors elle s'est pas posé
la question de c'est bien c'est mal
c'est 10000 € juste pour une clé USB et
on ne réfléchit plus encore une fois aux
conséquences euh avec aussi une naïveté
de certains opérateurs parce que vous
avez des des dockers qui parfois sont
entrés dans le système en disant c'est
one shot je le fais une fois je gagne le
pctol je me retire non on se retire pas
on est dans les griffes ensuite de ces
organisations là donc ça il faut bien le
comprendre il faut peut-être informer
les les gens aussi de que quand on met
un pied là-dedans on y bascule euh
fortement on se retire
pas aisément de ces choseslà alors ça
rejoint aussi en partie la question de
la criminalité forcée et des opérateurs
est-ce qu'ils ont peur oui il y en a qui
ont peur euh il y a des dockers les
dockers ne se comportent plus de la même
façon he ce du Havre avant ils vivaient
tous dans le même quartier ils étaient
fiers d'être docker ils le montraient
partout maintenant c'est profil bas
parce que ils savent qu'ils sont ciblés
euh parce que aussi ils savent qu'ils
sont plus contrôler et euh dans en
matière de corruption ce qui ce qui se
voit c'est que auparavant c'était
vraiment le gain qui les faisait
basculer on leur proposer alors en plus
ça change aussi le regard qu'on a sur la
corruption souvent en économie on
associe corruption à bas salaire ils
sont tellement mal payer que on va
compenser avec un revenu pour les
dockers c'est pas vrai ils sont bien
payés et ils acceptent quand même alors
là aussi c'est la déconnexion avec
l'éthique et euh maintenant on est plus
dans une logique de violence c'est on va
menacer les membres de la famille on on
suit les personnes on prend des photos
on dit voilà votre enfant on l'a vu à la
sortie de l'école si vous voulez c'est
nous qui allons le chercher donc là on
est dans dans dans cette logique là donc
bah ça joue aussi sur les douaniers même
s'ils continuent de faire leur travail
d'ailleurs moi je voudrais souligner la
centralité des douanes c'est un service
qui qui me tient à cœur qui est
fondamental parce que eux ils
travaillent sur la matérialité les
marchandises sur la territorialité parce
que il y a des territoires il y a des
frontières il faut aussi se reposer la
question des frontières je pense que
c'est important ils ont besoin de moyens
humains de moyens techniqu de dans les
opérations d'infiltration beaucoup se
disent que au moment du la
judiciarisation il va y avoir des
informations qui sortent sur les
infiltrés et que bah ça les met en
danger donc ils aimeraient plus de
protection là-dessus et je pense qu'en
terme de renseignement il y a beaucoup
de choses à faire on a beaucoup parlé de
follow the money follow the goods c'est
aussi très important les marchandises
elles parlent donc il faut pas se
contenter de saisir il faut étudier ces
marchandises en plus les criminels
souvent aiment bien marquer la
marchandise il y a le logo il y a donc
on peut apprendre plein de choses sur
ces marchandises donc il faut leur
donner des moyens pour faire parler plus
que les collaborateurs de justice la
marchandise va pouvoir parler autre
chose ce que je voudrais dire aussi en
terme de de de gestion de de ce problème
de trafic c'est qu'il y a un décalage
entre le temps court et le temps long la
politique c'est du temps court alors
c'est vrai que les points de Deal pu ça
a une dimension symbolique c'est le
territoire on serait approprié le
territoire en cartographiant en luttant
mais encore une fois ça n'impacte pas la
filière dans son ensemble ça ne permet
pas de de capter les les gros poissons
et là la coopération internationale est
fondamentale et c'est vrai qu'elle a
fait des avancées énormes c'est pour ça
le méga cartel d'europool le terme est
inapproprié mais la réussite elle est là
elle est vraiment réelle et importante
ça passe aussi par l'harmonisation des
législations c'est vrai que tous les
pays n'ont pas les mêmes par exemple les
écoutes c'est pas géré de la même façon
et ça ça peut provoquer des problèmes y
compris au niveau des procès hein pour
pour apporter des preuves il y en a qui
sont recevables dans certains pays pas
dans d'autres qu'est-ce qu'on fait
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas quand même à
planir les choses faciliter le travail
et pas aniler le travail parfois
d'enquête qui a pu être fait parce qu'on
n'est pas sur les mêmes choses dernière
chose sur ce rapport économie éthique
droit moi il me pose problème qu'on soit
dans un système économique on
criminalise le blanchiment de l'argent
salle tout en intégrant le trafic de
stupéfiants dans le calcul du PIB et le
taux de croissance de nos
économies merci pour ce paradoxe final
mon effectivement l'in intègre euh sous
les les injonctions d'une certaine
manière d'Eurostat euh l'économie de la
drogue dans dans justement les comptes
de la Nation pe parenthèse fermé
peut-être dire je je pourrais répondre
dans le désord mais revenir sur la
question du parcours du jeune trafiquant
euh je je je je dir et ça répondra en
partie aussi à la question de la Guyane
c'est-à-dire on ne n'est pas trafiquant
on le devient par définition et et et
donc quelles sont les les conditions
d'émergence juste justement de de ce
trafic donc on peut dire qu'il y a des
phénomènes pool comme on dire en anglais
des phénomènes pou pool ça c'est c'est
c'est aussi les gros trafiquants qui
savent utiliser les plus jeunes dans
l'organisation parce que ils sont
malléables parce que on on va les
sélectionn aussi j'avais écrit il y a
quelques années un article qui
s'appelait la canette et le sandwich qui
était la manière dont on a on on çonnait
les les jeunes dans le trafic
c'està-dire que un trafiquant va tenir
un plan un four pour revendre la drogue
il peut pas se déplacer donc il va
demander à un petit jeune d'aller lui
chercher une canette un sandwich qui a
un McDo un kebab que sais-je et euh et
moyen en quoi et il lui laisse la
monnaie ou alors il va pouvoir
sélectionner ceux qui sont les plus
fiables euh donc donc c'est une façon de
d'amçonner ces jeunes et phénomène
pouche c'est aussi parce que ces jeunes
sont attirés par par les lumières du du
du du prétendu gain facile alors que on
sait pertinemment qu' a il y a il y a
beaucoup de candidats mais il y a très
peu d'élus en vérité parce que il y a
aussi le mécanisme de de la répression
et et il y a des phénomènes
d'enfermement en fait dans dans dans le
trafic de ces plus jeunes alors ça
m'invite évidemment à à part aborder la
question sociale on peut pas faire
l'économie du social hein moi j'ai vu en
travaillant sur les quartiers la la
désertion de toute un ensemble de de
d'associations de travailleurs sociaux
c'est à mon avis ça a été la porte
ouverte pour les trafiquants
c'est-à-dire que il y a ce que j'ai dit
en introduction il y a une armée de
réserve qui est disponible euh s'il y a
pas justement de possibilités pour les
pouvoirs publics de de fournir une
alternative et et et d'occuper le
terrain d'ê d'être dans les quartiers
d'être présent et et et là on a on on a
un boulevard pour les trafiquants parce
qu'ils savent très bien comment les
utiliser ils savent très bien que les
peines en couru pour les mineurs sont
plus faibles que pour les majeurs et et
et donc je je je milite et et je prends
pas ma ma casquette de chercheur mais
plus casquet de citoyen pour pour pour
le le la mise en place de vraiment de de
d'un plan Marchal du soci dans dans dans
les quartiers pour couper cours
justement à tous ceux qui sont notamment
alors on on annulera pas totalement le
trafic he mais au moins tous ceux qui
sont sur cette ligne de crête là qui
savent pas je m'engage m'engage pas et
cetera B ceux on pourra justement les
RER les remèdes dans la République d'une
certaine
manière voilà et alors sur la Guyane
effectivement on y est allé avec David
on a bien vu je laisserai plus peut-être
répondre sur sur cette question
simplement de dire là aussi il y a
associatif qui est très dynamique et qui
permet de travailler avec les les zones
justement du côté de Saint-Laurent du
Maroni avec les différentes populations
c'est avec soit les bchinengé ou les
Amerindiens il y a il y a vraiment un
gros travail mais effectivement c'est
peut-être pas la hauteur de l'enjeu euh
et et et pour répondre à votre question
c'est vrai qu' a il y a eu cette on on a
vu le le le glissement depuis le
Suriname jusqu'en Guyane avec cette ce
dispositif qui a été mis en place
notamment à chipol euh dispositif de
d'un scanner un scanner très puissant
qui a qui qui a déporté ou reporté le
trafic pardon vers vers la Guyane et et
et donc il y a peut-être une réponse
technologique mais je suis pas certain
qu'elle soit fiable à 100 %.
euh dire peut-être de mots sur euh les
les la question a été posée sur le la
production la localisation euh la
destruction alors il y a y a un gros
travail qui est fait par les par les
autorités locales hein
euh le ça ça va dépendre de des des
drogues le principe des drogues de
synthèse c'est la déterritorialisation
c'està-dire qu'on peut les produire un
peu partout il suffit d'avoir les les
bons intrans les les bons produits
coupage et cetera et on peut les
produire donc la question de drog de
synthèse c'est une vraie une vraie
question épinos
ensuite la question du cannabis le
cannabis c'est c'est un produit qui qui
pousse un peu partout c'est extrêmement
difficile on on voit on voit bien que
qu' en Europe avec laquil la culture
indoor il il y a tout un marché de de de
cette économie indor et puis je pense
qu'on devrait se pencher aussi sur ce
qui se passe aux États-Unis au Canada en
matière de légalisation qui qui crée un
appel d'air aussi vers vers vers la
production
illégale enfin sur les les questions de
d'opium ça ça a été dit c'est localisé
mais là on retombe sur des des
problématiques de développement général
c'est-à-dire les les les tentatives de
de de substitution des plantes à drogue
n'ont pas produit les effets escomptés
parce que là aussi les gains restent en
DEA de ce qu'on peut peuvent
rapporter qui la culture de l'opium qui
culture de la feuille de coca voilà
peut-être je laisserai David apporter
des compléments sur sur ces
questions merci ben c'est à lui mon
berer merci euh benah je commence Paran
parce que bon j'ai j'ai un petit crush
pourve Guan j'ai vécu on a beaucoup
travaillé dessus effectivement euh on
continue à travailler dessus sur la
Guyane moi pour moi la Guyane c'est
comme je l'ai dit c'est la tête de pont
française face au narcotrafic de la
cocaïne c'est une problématique
régionale Nasser à justement parler du
Surinam on pourrait parler du Brésil
hein qui est la première porte de sortie
de la cocaïne du continent sud-américain
euh comme j'ai beaucoup travaillé dessus
et on continue d'ailleurs à soutenir des
jeunes chercheurs là je soutiens un
jeune chercheur guyanet qui est
extrêmement brillant et prometteur qui
travaille plutôt sur les passeurs mais
c'est vraiment très bien que les
Guyanais aussi s'empare de la recherche
sur ces sujets là mais je pense qu'on
est quand même sur un schéma régional
j'ai pour exemple une enquête
journalistique auquelle j'avais très
modestement contribué qui suivait le
parcours d'un passeur vénézuelien qui
depuis Caracas savait qu'il y avait des
départs à Cayenne avait été dans un
bureau de recrutement à Caracas donc il
avait été recruté par des groupes
criminels régionalisés il était parti à
manao au Brésil rejoindre une légion
d'autres passeurs qui étaient après
dissiminé dans l'ensemble des ports des
aéroports pour partir donc on voit bien
qu'on est sur des schémas
régionalisés extrêmement structurés avec
des groupes criminels très puissant qui
comme la dit Nasser recruteent à foison
chez les jeunes en derran qui ont peu
d'argent et cetera donc euh je sais pas
si ça va rassurer madame la sénatrice
mais on continue à travailler activement
sur la Guane alors sur la production il
y a aussi beaucoup de choses à dire
c'est c'est un élément très important
Naser l'a bien précisé il faut juste
souligner je pense que l'ancienne
dichotomie entre les pays producteurs et
les pays consommateurs les pays du Sud
et les pays du Nord n'existe plus le
cannabis si on regarde l' nudc les
rapports du c'est 190 pays au monde qui
produisent du cannabis Naser vous l'avez
précisé les drogues de synthèse se
produisent partout cannabis inclu
puisque la plupart du cannabis
maintenant est Souss ou indoor donc
cette diconomie elle existe encore pour
la cocaïne qui est produite que dans
trois pays mais les choses peuvent
évoluer puisquil y a des nouvelles
variétés qui permettent de produire dans
d'autres zones et dans une moindre
mesure suraghanistan et enfin sur
lesroïes avec
Afghanistan Birmanie et puis Amérique
Amérique latine et du Nord puisque le
Mexique est producteur de héroïne et la
Colombie aussi dans une moindre mesure
euh un je vous conseille d'aller voir
les publications de David Mansfield sur
l'Afghanistan qui montre bien la tension
entre la production de méthamphétamine
et d'opium qui peuvent aussi expliquer
autrement les mouvements de masse en
terme de production mais effectivement
c'est un sujet important je reviens très
vite aussi sur le lien entre le
terrorisme et le narcotrafic c'est un
sujet qui nous avait occupé sur une
étude qui n'a jamais abouti mais on
avait quand même identifié des points de
jonction qui sont euh clatit l'a évoqué
en début
d'audition des
facilitateurs ce que Douglas fara
appelle les facilitateurs qui sont des
gens qui sont dont leur valeur ajoutée
de mettre en contact l'économie légale
l'économie légale que ce soit des
narcotrafiquants et aussi l'économie
enfin les groupes illégaux qui sont des
terroristes sachant que la définition de
terrorisme est un concept mou pour le
chercheur puisque voilà c'est c'est des
organisations qui ont un objectif
politique et qui qui sont considérés à
un moment té comme comme terroristes
mais effectivement partons de la
classification terroriste internationale
européenne et français il y a ces liensl
qui sont présents qui passent aussi par
les Dirty ban que que que clotild a
évoqué avec quand même des logiques qui
sont pas exactement les mêmes he puisque
il y il y a des logies il faut récupérer
de l'argent qui est pas forcément
illégale pour financer les actions
politiques terroristes et mais qui
peuvent être légal il a il y a des des
cas historiques étayés et puis l'autre
logique c'est de blanchir l'argent ou en
tout cas le sécuriser pour pouvoir
l'utiliser souvent dans les manières
consuméristes les liens existent ils
sont complexes ils sont volatiles et il
est extrêmement difficile de faire des
lignes directrices très clair sur le
sujet mais c'est un sujet qui qui quand
même mérite d'être évoqué
euh je pense j'essaie de répondre aussi
aux questions qui ont pas trop été
répondu vous voulez qu'on non mais ce
qui n'est pas sorti là on peut le on
peut le réserver à votre réponse écrite
si vous si vous souhaitezord et puis du
coup je pense que ienne blanc a quelques
oui merci on a obtenu une foule
d'informations qui nous sert utiles et
qui vont
orienter nos recherches et les questions
que nous poserons plus tard si vous me
le perettez moi j'ai trouvé deux points
sur lesquels dans vos réponses écrites
vous devriez vous
appesantir de manière à étayer nos
travaux le premier point ce sont les
liens que vous vous pouvez avoir entre
vos laboratoires au dispositifs de
recherche et les technologies et
sciences nouvelles et on a parlé de la
Guyane et des scanners on a aujourd'hui
des dispositifs qui évoluent très
rapidement et qui permettent de scanner
à la
fois le physique d'une personne mais
aussi les containire on a été frappé
dans les échanges que nous avons eu on
pourra prendre un container il est en
métal il est protégé on arrive à savoir
ce qu' a à l'intérieur à connaître la
masse à connaître la couleur à connaître
les formes et à repérer avec des
logiciels
adaptés il faudrait peut-être que vous
nous disiez comment
euh se passent les échange entre vos
dispositifs de recherche et ces
entreprises privées qui aujourd'hui
travaillent sur ces technologie nouvell
euh c'est quelque chose qui nous paraît
important et deuxièmement euh nous avons
tous été
frappés quand on nous a donné des
informations sur le chiffre d'affaires
que génère la drogue en France pour
parler en termees génériquees on est
entre 4 et 7 milliards vous difficile à
apprécier précisément enfin 4 et 7
milliards dans l'économie française ça
se voit qui plus est ce sont des flux
qui sont des flux
euh monétaires en argent et en argent
liquide ça se voit ça c'est ça ça se
voit plus facilement que le numérique
même si on a des dispositifs de
surveillance et euh on trouve que les
saisies on trouve que la surveillance on
trouve que le contrôle de ces flux de
ces petits flux qui en fait euh
remontent ensuite euh vers des
trafiquants plus importants et ils sont
très très mal surveillés ils sont très
très mal connus alors on sait on a
intuitivement au moment des fêtes de
Noël on va voir les grandes marque qui
vont faire un chiffre d'affaires
absolument considérable et qu'on sait
quand on fait des saisies qu'on trouve
du Louis Vitton on trouve de l'hermè on
trouve de l'or on trouve des bijous on
trouve des Rolex et cetera mais c'est
pas à proportion de ces qure à 6
milliards et là-dessus on serait très
très preneur de suggestions
euh de piste de travail parce qu'en fait
on le sait si on arrive à tarir ces
petits réseaux et ben c'est l'ensemble
de la filière qu'on arrive et et que
l'on parvient à déstabiliser mais on a
relativement peu de moyens aujourd'hui
pour contrôler justement c'est C
économie souterraine du quotidien qui se
fait en
espèce j'ajoute une question que on vous
laissera le le mot final vous avez
commencé votre propos monsieur bizou sur
de deux schémas l'hyperrépressif et
celui de la légalisation donc je termine
quand même parce que je veux poser cette
question de la légalisation et que vous
prononciez les uns et les autres
sur son opportunité ses difficultés ses
limites ses échecs voilà alors une
minute 30 ce sera pour man
noterin juste moi je suis très intéressé
par le modèle québécois voilà s'il y a
un modèle qui me paraît pertinent et
intéressant c'est le modèle québécois
sur le cannabis pourquoi le Québec était
contre la
légalisation la légalisation a été
imposée par le gouvernement fédéral le
Québec a été obligé de s'y mettre ils y
sont allés à reculon ça a été un échec
massif les deux premières années
aujourd'hui les résultats c'est
impressionnant c'est impressionnant moi
je leur avais donné 5 à 10 ans pour
réussir à avoir un impact sur le marché
illicite en 3 ans ils l'ont eu c'estd
que on est à 40 % de
baisse de du volume
financier
mobilisé perdu par le trafic par rapport
à l'offre légale et l'offre légale
représente 60 % de l'activité
donc ça a été super efficace et il y a
pas de transfert il y a pas
d'augmentation des consommations on a
une augmentation uniquement des
expérimentateurs c'est-à-dire bah comme
c'est légal une fois dans une soirée
plutôt que de l'alcool les gens vont
essayer un joint et ça s'arrête là donc
on a vraiment à regarder de près leur
rapport leur dernier bilan va sortir
d'ici en principe une semaine donc moi
je le regarderai avec avec attention
c'est très très intéressant comme
expérimentation merci
mage moi je suis contre alors bon déjà
suivant les drogues on peut ou pas
envisager les choses pour la cocaïne il
est évident que non l'héroïne non plus
la question C légalisation cannabis Mar
très très bien depuis 20 ans en Suisse
ouais ça fonctionne parfaitement même
pour le cannabis pour moi c'est pas une
solution parce que légalisé n'est pas
libéralisé c'est-à-dire que il y a un
encadrement par l'État et à partir du
moment où vous encadrez une activité il
y a des acteurs qui vont contourner cet
encadrement donc on ne fait pas
disparaître le trafic il y aura aussi un
marché parallèle qui va peut-être jouer
sur les différents de teneur en THC donc
c'est extrêmement problématique ça ne
fait pas disparaître les organisations
criminelles du tout en plus elles sont
multiactivité donc à la limite ça ça les
affecte peu parce que il y a des
conséquences aussi dans la consommation
des drogues on voit la conduite prendre
son véhicule sous l'effet de stupéfiant
ça a des conséquences et on est dans une
société où encore une fois on on pense
plus CX conséquence donc la personne se
dit mais si moi je vois très bien je
suis j'ai de bons réflexes et puis ben
non et là c'est ce sont d'autres que les
consommateurs qui qui payent et puis euh
encore une fois je suis dans une logique
de reconnexion de l'économie au droit
euh plutôt qu'à la logique de marché
c'est pas parce qu'il y a une offre et
une demande que on doit créer un marché
et valider ce marché c'est euh une
décision politique on doit faire des
choix on doit pas subir le les dictates
économiques il y a un rapport au droit
ce qui fait société c'est d'établir des
frontières des interdits et reculer
enfin enfin abaisser un interdit parce
que on considère que il y a trop
d'infraction à cet interdit ben c'est
c'est problématique sur la cohésion
sociale
merci alors moi je serais plutôt
partisan justement de d'observer ce qui
se passe dans dans tous les pays qui ont
notamment légalisé le le le cannabis
dans un premier temps puis voir s'il y a
eu d'autres expériences ailleurs et de
et de d'objectiver justement de manière
très précise ce qui se passe à la fois
sur un plan sanitaire
qu de la consommation augmentation pas
augmentation la
criminalité l'impact sur les ressources
publiques c'est-à-dire l'utilisation de
la justice des services de police qui
seront qui qui seraient amenuisé du fait
de la
légalisation la la la question
de des effets par exemple sur la la
conduite sur sur route tout ces toutes
ces dimensions il faut à mon avis les
les documenter et puis et puis ensuite
tirer des conclusions sur justement
qu'est- qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qui
est pertinent ou pas ensuite c'est au
politiques de s'en emparer moi je serais
d'avis de vraiment de documenter au plus
près à travers des études des recherches
précise regardez faire un état de l'art
en France maintenant on peut compter sur
un certain nombre de pays qui ont qui
ont légalisé peut-être demain
l'Allemagne va légaliser est-ce que
est-ce que est-ce que
pardon donc est-ce que est-ce est-ce que
ça ça va changer on va changer de
paradigme ou pas donc est-ce qu'il y a
pas un effet masse à un moment donné qui
fait que la pense devra ça ou
non changer de de dimension à ce point
ce point de
vueberger mais excuse l'Allemagne a
priori a annoncé la semaine dernière
qu'elle rétop pédalé un peu sur sur son
projet
mars alors évidemment observer et tirer
conséquences on ne peut que souscrire à
la proposition de Naser alors j'étais il
y a 1 an et demi à la grand messe de la
recherche des drogues Lisbonne addiction
et je discutais avec les de la recherche
sur l'égalisation que sont Bokin mer et
Rosalie PAKOUA des Américains qui
étaient très gêné parce qu'effectivement
les résultats notamment sanitaires en
terme de consommation alors sur les
expérimentations américaines et
canadiennes hors Québec sont pas
positive et donc là ils étaient un petit
peu ennuyés sur cette espèce
d'engouement au début qui était vraiment
une idée qu'on qui est agréable de
pouvoir avoir une baguette magique un
changement législa qui va régler plein
de problèmes et là en tout cas sur les
modèles très business friendly
nordaméricain sur le plan la santé
publique c'est pas un résultat positif
et on avait fait une étude il y a
quelques années avec Naser et avec l'
FDT sur les premières
expérimentations je rejoins le discours
de claud qui est que on ne voit pas de
résultat vertuueux sur la
criminalité même si il y a une partie de
économique qui réinjejecté dans le
circuit légal de manière relativement
mécanique en revanche les groupes
criminels s'adaptent et comme toujours
ce sont les plus petits les plus
modestes qui trinqu vous voulez avoir le
mot de la fin madame jeche non juste
pour ajouter justement sur l'impact sur
les acteurs la mocrafia ses début c'est
l'approvisionnement des coffee shop puis
la prise de contact avec les la cocaïne
et cetera et la monté en puissance mais
justement les Pays-Bas n'ont jamais
légalisé c'est tout le problème ils ont
dépénalisé ce qui est une erreur massive
parce que vous ouvrez un marché légal au
trafic et donc ce que viennent de
démarrer mais l'expérimentation démarre
là le 15 décembre ils vont démarrer une
légalisation on va voir ce que ça va
donner bon VO qu' un débat vif et qui
mérite d'être poursuivi on vous remercie
très chaleureusement pour votre présence
votre disponibilité on attend
impatiemment vos écrits merci
monsieur